for me i think i'm coming i know you are
i know you are i'm gonna stream on this
let me tell you here's the thing spike
real quick real quick about this hold on
hold on real quick on this because this
is important because you really have
known a lot more wealthy famous people
for a lot longer than i and i appreciate
your writing down because you don't want
to forget your point i like that um i'm
telling you right now this is a big one
for me
tell these people because this is big
explain to them how many
millionaires you know that are deeply
unhappy
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
[Music]
all right everybody obviously
legends come through here once in a blue
moon the blue moon is fully out
uh if you're watching the visual my man
is repping the yankees today uh most of
you are accustomed to him repping my
knicks so uh
uh i i adore this man he is truly a
creative storytelling legend uh i'm
excited to have him on the podcast we've
been talking for a year and a half about
nfts so i'm excited to see his journeys
going on that i want to talk a little
knicks basketball i want to talk a
little bit about creativity and
storytelling because i think that will
help the majority of people but the
great spike lee is in the building how
are you sir
good and it's honored to be on
garyvee's
show
thank you big now i'll big tom
you made it
by the way i really got excited because
watching the oscars i see you donated a
bunch of stuff they they played that
prominently at the museum
it's now a donation
let's start with the important stuff how
disappointed or
how
optimistic depending on you know rj's
developments and things that nature
let's go first into knicks we're
wrapping up here on the season obviously
we're not in the playoffs which was a
minimal goal for us going into this
season
last year too
correct where your feelings at
well if you remember the
opening
night
our beloved new york knicks beat the
boston celtics in devil overtime
yep and
people lost their mind
that lost
blocked their mind jumping up and down
and you fully outside mass for a garden
like we just won the nba
championship
i just i was i was in the building the
night the rangers won the cup
and i walked out and people were going
bananas and the fact of the matter is it
wasn't that big of a difference people
that viral video
bing-bong this like we were out of our
mind
and i think that that
show how
desperate
the new york one of the most loyal fan
base in sports not just nba
how we are starving for
a winning team
we have now we've had
two world championships in the history
of new york knicks
75 year history new york knicks
my beloved 6970 team
and also my beloved 72-73 team so we
have not won a championship since ninth
this 1972-73
season a lot of close calls
but
no cigar
no cigar no 1994 was the rough one
that was the one
against it is houston we're up three two
one back use of the game six and seven
and what's tough about that is i you
know obviously it would have played out
but that sam cassell
shot in game three
i you know obviously i think houston
would have been more desperate in game
four and five and
the human psyche who knows how it would
have went but
it's that sam cassell three that i think
about most
even more you know people talk about the
stark game people talk about a lot of
different things but that sam cassell's
shot like
tore through my heart
here's the thing though
we cannot deal with hakeem olajuwon he's
a
beast he was a beast you know
historically now you know i love pastors
going all the way back to georgia love
them
love them but if you go
in there
when they went head to head
the keem had the edge he did he did and
that was displayed in the in that seven
game series
and i'm not blaming half the lord
patrick you go way way back yeah by the
way with all due respect to
his incredible cast
like
and the oak tree i mean i love mason
starks
roe harper like
patrick ewing is incredibly underrated
in my opinion on how like you know some
of the like people just forget they
forget
i mean that was his team by a country
mile wasn't even close
and if you look at the yeah
put that team on his back
yeah like you know i think people forget
otis thorpe against oakley what that
matchup actually looked like like i
think people are i think people listen
it is what it is when you're at the top
of a team but anyway all right got got a
little knicks off because i needed to do
that let's let's focus on the thing that
i really want to most talk about because
whether it was commercials whether it
was movies
even just when i have dinner with you
like or we interact on courtside for a
few seconds like
you have such a natural
communication talent you as a human
being
you as a storyteller
there the world is getting more creative
if you look at the current state of
attention
tik tok and nfts have created
avenues of distribution and financial
opportunity for storytellers unseen and
heard of what makes you such a legend
i mean it wasn't that the technology
what about gary you garyvee you know
there's been anybody
the technology brought about
accessibility to people who
didn't have it
correct
global
correct
and and especially interesting is you
know you growing up you had to break so
many barriers the barriers now are set
up the app on your phone and you're in
the game right
as a universal
thing to think about because there's so
many of those creative people listening
right now right
if somebody says to you talk about
storytelling i'm a young person there's
two people on this
two groups right now that i'm very
passionate that you talk to
youth under 25
under 30
aspiring storytellers whatever that
means for them an nft artist a physical
artist a movie maker a scriptwriter a
tick talker creativity is profound now
and
more interestingly or equally
interestingly
the 42 year old who's an executive works
in the government uh a teacher a
stay-at-home dad mom uh someone who
has finally listened to my content
enough to know they're gonna live for
another 60 years and they're like [ __ ]
it i've always wanted to be creative and
now i can do this
on the side why this thing and if it
pops off i can go do it full time
give me some overarching spikely legend
wisdom on what's a good way to think
about creativity from your perspective
and your journey not only you and how
you do it but others you've admired and
meant through the last 40 years that
you're like oh that's her process oh
that's his process what should be the
thought process or some hypotheses of
how to get there and be successful at it
well i want to thank you gary vee for
lobbing a big fat one a big fat juicy
fastball you're wearing you're a
lot a softball
right down on the little plate
and i i for
i'm in my fourth decade as a filmmaker
and i i speak
all the time at universities and in
colleges and one of the things i always
try to try to strive i try to hit home
is that over the years
over the decades
parents have killed
more dreams
i'm gonna repeat that
parents have killed more dreams anybody
and this is specifically when we come to
the arts
parents can understand
what you why you go to med school
i go to business school
but when it comes to the art many
parents
have no understanding
how to become an actor
a dancer
a riot a poetry a poet a painter
whatever it is the arts is some type of
mystical thing
and
and parents want the best for their
children a hundred percent and they
think in their wisdom
they could give the vice
to
[Music]
their children nothing
want to do with the traditional
work thing
do you think fear parents
do you think yeah
and a lot of times
knowing
how parents
might have took a second mortgage on the
house and whatnot and done everything
so you can go to
a great undergrad school and the bills
and these student loans are crazy
and so there comes that parental
pressure and also guilt knowing that
what our parents have done
and many years later these individuals
who took their parents advice and did
not pursue
was in their
heart end up many years later hating
their parents
because
they are stuck
in a den and job
because
one of the things that could be closer
to death without dying
is having to give every morning
and go to a job you hate
i mean that does not bring joy to
anybody although you get joy for your
your family your wife your partner your
kids but i'm talking about where the
thing you have to do
to keep roof over the head
food on the table
clothes in the back and you hate that
job
you are
a miserable [ __ ]
100
miserable
so
what
technology has done
has really enlightened
the education of parents like oh
i don't have to work my son doesn't have
to go to
be a lawyer doc whatever and do the
traditional the traditional route to
make a living
and they see examples of this again and
again and again even though they might
they might not
understand at the beginning
but
people are making
more money
in the arts
when my mama just made me to survive
then this ever happened in the history
of civilization
and i think that's
that's making people happier because
again i know i might be
you know redundant but when you and i
here's the thing gary garyvee my brother
i say my prayers every night
i'm healthy but also
i'm doing what i love a hundred percent
michael jordan michael i mean as many
people said this
when you if you could make a living have
to be a millionaire but if you could
make a living
if you can pay your this is what well
this is this is
that's the win that's another we have to
we have to
have to it's our responsibility as happy
people and whoever's out there is happy
we have to try to reframe success in
society not being about money material
but being peace of mind and enjoying
your day-to-day process i was equally as
happy making 42 000 a year building a
business
it was for my father as i am today where
i make a lot more money than that well
let's not go overboard
no really it's like for me for me i
here's the thing spike real quick real
quick hold on hold on real quick on this
because this is important because you
really have known a lot more wealthy
famous people for a lot longer than i
and i appreciate your writing down
because you don't want to forget your
point i like that um i'm telling you
right now this is a big one for me
tell these people because this is big
explain to them how many
millionaires you know that are deeply
unhappy
too many
to name
yeah but i would like to say because
there's a converse
i mean there's a there's the flip side
is
which
this
romantic thing
of being the starving artist [ __ ] that
right
money doing your art
yeah yeah listen no point that star an
artist thing
make
money on your art
talk to me about
the first time let me actually ask you a
question i think could bring a lot of
value
this might be hard i don't know if you
can if you remember it if it was a big
deal i don't know this so i'm asking for
the first time i haven't asked you this
the internet
when you first heard the internet you
know what's amazing about the blockchain
is it allows people to make money on
their art what the internet did was not
it democratized things it had a lot of
copyright issues we forget because it
was 25 years ago but you and i are old
enough to remember those early days you
were in a very prime position of your
career i could be very empathetic
no different than metallica and other
people i could be very empathetic if
spike lee
1994-5678 when i was first hitting the
scene was like whoa whoa whoa whoa what
do you mean somebody's got do the right
thing video like am i what you know
because the world had come from you own
that [ __ ] um and now hearing you say
that inspired this question were you
concerned anti or pro curious or like
late to the party or early to the party
i actually don't know can you tell it
because i think this will help people
with blockchain were you where were you
with with internet 94567
i'm ashamed to say
i was late
i appreciate you for saying that i owe
so much
if you're my age and you got children
they're like daddy
i need today i need my children to turn
on the television
yeah i'm a dinosaur i'm sorry
i'm just of that i was born march 20
1957
the first day of spring i just turned
65. happy birthday my friend
thank you so
um
i've been late
you know but
here's the thing though is that why you
were so nft curious because you felt it
with what internet children they they
did they've taken upon themselves
they hit their daddy they're like daddy
music
tv shows
internet mts
i mean
i owe a lot to them because
and stuff and gary you know stuff is
coming so quick so fast it's like like
this i'm getting whiplash i can't keep
up
so
i owe a lot to my
the knowledge that i'm gaining to my
parents because
these this young generation i forgot
what alphabet it is now i don't know
what else
they're on it
and
i come over a time period where this is
funny
when you when you had to study
you would sit in the room
your room or the library
you can't talk you got to stop
my kids
they got and then i'm just i think
they're like they weren't the only ones
that they're doing their homework the
tv's on
the laptop song
they're on their phone
and they got earphones
yep and you're doing the homework
i don't get it
we're
we're capable
i think
look there's many different viewpoints
but for me when i'm doing something i
gotta concentrate on what i'm doing the
task in hand and not have
that's just me
so when i see your point
yeah i know they're doing it but i don't
i just can't understand if if i don't
have if i don't have
music i mean i sleep with a sound
machine i need white noise like i this
is why i [ __ ] with new york so heavy i
need i need it i need the stimulation i
can focus more music
ins imessage popping up with
notifications i can lock in more it gets
me more in the zone quieter got me off
yeah exactly i look differently
that's why that's what's so fun about it
school
when you when you um so internet you
were late did you fight it or you were
just busy making movies and you're like
i'll get to that later or were you like
[ __ ] i don't like this
no i was i was interested because when
the term i first heard the term email
like
email
i mean i i'm from a generation where
you took pen
to paper and you wrote
yes
pen to paper i wrote letters
postcards
you know
love letter love
this with two thumbs
gives me
an iphone
one
yeah you're one you're you're an index
finger i got you
i like that it's all i can do
my thumbs aren't
educated
when you storytell like when you make a
movie
do you do you write do you scribble
random thoughts is it all in your dome
imp how do you how much do you like
improving when you make your f do you
change it like how do you play
well again
i
i don't i can't type i feel typing and
john do the high school in coney island
you know dewey cody
so
i don't have that so everything i've
done
gary is pen
the paper
and for me
there's something magical about
the float from my brain
i'm left-handed too
i see it creativity
and
i look everybody's built differently i
said before but to do this
that it floats yeah it flows differently
oh it clogs what what what about what
about when you start making it it was
written one way it flowed
like
once i have written it out i got you it
gets it flows one way it's in your brain
but what about when it's in the moment
of capturing the scene
does it sometimes it felt one way in
your head but now that you're seeing it
you're like yo let's change that up are
you good at the adjustment oh yes yes
you got to be able to look this this
this thousands of analogies you could
make you could make behind
creativity and sports
first half ain't going right you make
half time adjustment
[Music]
adjustment also
gary film is a very creative
art form so it's not just what i think
yes you don't think i listen to denzel
washington details he gives me a note
horse of course now some other people
well you know i'm [ __ ] but denzel
i'm like all right denzel all right d
listen actually actually let me ask you
that in the history of your films which
is iconic
which
actor impro what is the most famous
scene that we all know
or even if it's to the hardest core
spikely film nerd
that
was most affected by an actor in full
improv it stayed it was nothing what you
thought and it's a thing that people can
point to and it's a moment is there
anyone
yes please i'm now i'm excited my
morehouse brother
who just finally won his
yes oscar family
here's the thing
i did not know sam had a substance abuse
problem
when i cast him for
jungle fever
the crackhead son
by the great late ruby and ozzy davis
and also played wesley's knife's brother
so
all that stuff
that he did with ruby d
and also stuff with halle berry
harry bell harry hat
her role was vivian the three dollar
crackhole funny story
she auditioned five times
wow
because the first four
fine as she is
i didn't believe
that
she wasn't she wasn't right you dollar
crack
me you two fine
and the fifth time
robbie reed my casting director
told her
you got a comment dressed like
vivian's i think she can take her
legend is
she didn't
bathe for a week and just came in like
a crack and she got departed and the
rest is history
but all those scenes in the park
and also
the mythic scene where they go to the
taj mahal
or the crackdown
oh that's a lot of that stuff was uh
sam's a great great
you know he could do it and then also a
lot of the funniest lines
in the capital one
campaigns that charles saying what i've
been doing for the last nine years a lot
of funniest lines with lines were
ad-libbed by samuel jackson
it's amazing
yeah i mean now that performance was all
time and so a lot of that you know
that's what happens when it's authentic
yeah
100 i had no idea
i understand talk to me about um
the people that have inspired you that
you would deem as creative and
entrepreneurship is creative music
obviously is going to be an easy one i'm
actually that let's just go very narrow
as a child
pre-pre-college let's talk it 17 and
under
who were your favorite music artists
prince
prince prince prince was must have been
later right because prince
let me go let me go childhood and then
yeah i finished i finished high school i
finished i graduated from john due high
school in columbia in 1975. i finished
morris college in
in 179 and i finished in when you
graduate film school in 82. so you tell
me
what era
yeah i mean i'm more interested in like
the 60s or actually even like jack i was
curious you're if you're you know so
cliche of the of that era
so many people were affected by their
parents and grandparents when you're a
kid everywhere for that matter so i was
wondering if it was jazz or if it was
something else because then later motown
clearly
would have been dominant for you and
everybody the world and then obviously
it evolved obviously princeton 75 is
good
but i'm going to start so my father's
building
world famous jazz basis did the scores
for a lot of my films
at one time he was the number one fault
basis
my father played with bob dylan
peter paul and mary
judy collins gordon lightfoot i mean a
bunch of people
so
in our home note it was always jazz's
play and so me and my siblings like my
father here was my father here anything
other than jazz in the house you say
turn up whether the beatles or motown
turn it off
turn it off so
even though
my love of jazz came from
my father but i still
have a wide range of
of my faith
i mean being a kid of the 60s and 70s
music scene forget it
so i have a wide range of music that's
reflected and you know in the in the
music has been in my films
but uh motown
you know just the world
gotta give you know give load the
marvin gaye the supreme
temptations you know we go
loaded
what about physical art
or collectibles did you collect comic
books as a kid oh my
god in my office here in brooklyn my
office is like museum
growing up
the reason why
my office looks like
it's a museum is because i was i've
always been a collector growing up i
collected marvin excuse me more comic
books growing up i collected baseball
cards
did you play basketball cards because
you loved it so much
basketball football
baseball you know i was collector you
know me my friends and i
i mean we we knew back in the day
the visiting team stayed the roseville
hotel at madison avenue
so when the san francisco giants came to
new york to play the mets we were there
at the hotel wait for willie mays
mccully
when the braves came what we waiting for
hank garrett
when the pittsburgh pirates came we're
waiting for the birthday
and you know sometimes
the people they would kick us out of
someone at a hotel
but who was actually that's a fun one
who was the athlete that was nicest to
you when you were a child signed an
autograph or told you a story or like
chopped it up for a second does that i
think so for me it was rick
walt frazier yes when i was growing up
here in brooklyn my guys
muhammad ali
willie mays
joe willie namath right there it will
praise you
so those were
my guys those are my heroes and so i
feel blessed as a little kid going to
brooklyn new york
i got to meet these guys
i think who i was
and and and clyde was amazing when you
brought in
that was my favorite guy there's a jazz
club my father should play at
on the west side called west boondock
and clyde used to be all coming in all
the time and one day my father came home
and said
well fraser the club last night and he
he's signed the autograph for me
you lost your mind
yes clyde
clyde
bonnie and cl that man what a what a
legend two-time hall of famer yes
broadcast and as a player
unbelievable all right what about let's
talk about something else that i think a
lot of people here are going to go
through given our audience
how did you handle financial success for
the first time did you do it well did
you do it poorly what did it and then
even fame because you got fame along
with that as well a lot of more people
are going to be famous now because of
tick tock instagram youtube the world's
different now more habit
what piece of advice and then obviously
you've seen a lot of people on their
come up
go from undiscovered to very famous even
even [ __ ] michael jordan when you
were doing your commercials was in a
different place than he went on to
become what a first you
how did you handle it b
any advice for the kids that are
destined for that outcome of things to
keep in mind or cliche mistakes people
have made
very good question
i never my goal was never to be rich
i wanted to
be able to be happy
doing what i love
and i remember
before my first film she's gonna have it
hit
i said if i lord
lordy lordy lord
here's three things i want
i want to be able to have enough money
to buy a brownstone
in brooklyn new york i grew up in a
brownstone right if that happens
if that wouldn't have nothing that might
also have enough enough money to buy
season tickets to new york knicks
the third thing was
lord
i want people to have to buy a house and
mother's vineyard
and the lord bless me
so
the thing is that
i grew up in a middle class
family
but
with the exception of miles davis some
other people duke
count basie there was not a lot of money
being a jazz position
so
my as i said before my father's the top
the viewers the go-to guy for folk
artists
when bob dylan went electric
my father said
i can't do that to this day father's 93
he's never played electric bass
who was your father who's your father's
two questions favorite artist on skill
and then famous artist as a human being
do you know
john coltrane
for both both get the [ __ ] out of here
yes so
when my father
made the artistic decision
that he can't play electric bass
my mother had to work
because it really affected the financial
status what
let me tell you something
if you don't pay the bill the broken
union gas
it's going to shut off again
you don't pay
because because at that point
you like
chris because because
dylan was the biggest financial aspect
at that point and once he couldn't make
that move do that move he had to reset
mm-hmm so i'm the i'm the eldest of five
so
my mother
because she believed that my father is
an artist
she was a sole breadwinner
oh she's supported yeah
before my mom if i was working
she'd have to work [ __ ]
a card the bloomingdale's for the taylor
and
well that when that my father said i
can't flood up your base and hire him
because when people on angel bob dylan
said i'm going to love to
everybody
i see
everybody did
so
and i had feel about
my father making that decision because i
knew how hard
my mother was working to support the
full family but then as i've gotten
older i've come to understand that he's
an artist and there were just some
things that
he wasn't watching
that's right it wasn't a compromise
so
i
money is
i don't want to say
i didn't need money for me to be happy
but at the same time as i mentioned
earlier
i did not believe in this whole thing of
this this
starving
starving arts because yeah i was
because
your filmmaker i wanna make
i wanna reap
the business of my artistry
it makes a lot of sense to me as an
entrepreneur the way i think about it is
this is the only thing i could do it is
when i was a bad student unlike you it's
i i can only be this
and
if the byproduct is you know obviously
with entrepreneurship if you're good at
it and i'm real good at it like it's
real serious
that gets real serious but that's the
luck of the dna draw because if i wanted
to draw or sing or or paint or play
sports i mean i think about you know
both you and i are sports fanatics i
think about all the guys and gals
that um
that
went for it
and what's tough about sports is
injuries of variable you know with me
with entrepreneurship a coconut has to
hit my head and reprogram me otherwise
i'm good in sports
you know when i think about sam bowie
or greg odin if we're going to talk some
basketball right like two like
injuries are really
tragic too bad you know like if the
body's held up or if an injury you know
it's a very different outcome and so you
know i think about all the people but i
but i so associate with your father and
you
of
i know for fact that nobody knows this
for me not my parents not anybody
listening right now that if
what i do was a 63 000 a year job then
that would be [ __ ] amazing to me i
would live within the means of 63 000
and i did that
my whole life and so i think um it's
very fortunate when there's a financial
aspect to the serendipity of your
passion yeah and that's why i love nfts
and let's actually close out with that
oh that's because
was that we're doing that was a segway
yeah well listen i just looked at the
clock i got a hardcore 145 and i wanna i
want to really ask you this because i
have a lot of friends who are in very
power positions who are staying away
from
the um the nft space out of lack of
curiosity and of out of lack of interest
in putting in the homework and one of
the reasons i wanted you on the podcast
was it struck me
um we've always had mutual friends
through the years but we've never really
chopped it up and when the nft thing
went down i could sense your energy that
you intuit can i reach out to you
mm-hmm
and so i think to for that reason
please help other people who are really
pronounced in their careers
whether in front of the scenes or behind
the scenes
what made you
really curious about it or interested
what gave you the engine to go at it and
what have you learned in the last year
and what would you say to the people who
are still debating it
based on what you've learned and what
you're seeing
well thank you
as i said before i've been behind and
through
my son jackson and my daughter satchel
you know is your daughter is your
daughter named after satchel paige
it's
yes
so and also we got we got a
bastiat
this is funny
so again i have to give it to my
children and said daddy
you've been late the other things but
don't sleep on this
and so
i did i do here's a thing
and and i know you say this a million
times
but you have to put the work in
and i spell like rihanna
w-e-r-k
work
whatever you're doing
you have to put the work in whatever
and
when i
saw the potential
of nfts
and being a creative person
and what automatically clicked for me is
that
my first film
she's gonna have it which i all had to
die to make it the initial the budget
was
the initial budget with my first film
she's gonna have it
came out 1986
cost 175 000
it went to make eight and a half million
dollars at the box office
and
i own that film
i don't do the right thing i own malcolm
x
i don't own school days i don't inside
man i own
she's gonna have it and she's gonna have
it where the world was entered
introduced
to the original sneakerhead
one of the b boys mars blackman who blew
up who
the advertising agency nike's
advertising agency wiring kennedy saw
she could have it and saw that
mars was wearing jordans and as favorite
players michael jordan they got the
brilliant idea
to put
mars together
with michael jordan and it changed the
[ __ ] game
it changed both of your lives yes
so i own this cat i said
boom
shakalaka i gotta come out for the nft
for mars blackman
yep
what what is it it so
is it gonna be just a collectible is
there gonna be utility i'm not up to
date
i've assembled a team
yeah do me a favor because we're gonna
run out of time here i just want this
for my own personal send me the info on
that obviously that was a quintessential
moment and you know i was born in 75
growing up in queens and jersey
predominantly in jurors but like that
was you know besides the fact that i
hated michael jordan from the get
because i knew it was going to be
trouble like you know spike tell all the
kids that don't know those early years
very much lost in history especially
after losing to the pistons over and
over right before he broke through
against the lakers those last two years
before he broke through against the
lakers the volume got real loud that
he'll never win one i can remember kids
in sixth grade debating michael will
never win one he's two ball greedy ball
hog remember i mean this was a people
forget but i even knew back when you did
that commercial i said
[ __ ] he's got he's in he's in our
conference
eventually it's going to happen
and it happened and it really happened
and it really happened the world changed
so i want to thank you just again for
for first of all for being my friend
and and i really appreciate
that the thing i love about you gary is
that there are people that have
information that don't share it
i know you share information
you share information
and that
is the professor
you are a professor
that's what that's what teaching
professors do they teach
because they want people to be educated
whatever the subject matter is
ignorance
is [ __ ] up
it's it's the great vulnerability of our
lives it's where so much hate and anger
and sadness comes from
and to your point it's incredibly rare
in entrepreneur land for people to share
information because the information is
money
and they want to hoard it correct
and something in the way
tamara vaynerchuk raised me
back to something that i've become
really aware of which is if you grow up
with not a lot of finances but you grow
up very happy you're pretty much in the
best position to succeed in life because
you've learned that that's not based on
happiness and then finally
the big breakthrough for me somewhere
along the line
i realized i wasn't taught this i
learned it by living
that the world is actually abundant and
other people winning
even if it looks directly in your game
other people winning will never stop an
a player from winning there is not a
human on earth
all the entrepreneurs i admire none of
them
not she not he not she not he not she
not he
that they're winning takes any way
shape or form away from my winning and
for me
whether one-on-one over a nice bottle of
wine with you or whether in my discord
or
car bone big
for me for me
all i want is to see everybody else win
now am i competitive do i want to like
do i want to be the best of course i
want to be the best i'm curious if i am
the best i want to operate the other
stuff though correct and by the way it's
even better than that when chris sacca
and scott belski when we were all angel
investing back in oh five six seven
eight nine ten
i'm pumped to just name drop both of
them right now they did a better job
angel investing than i did and that
makes i actually like losing a little
bit i just want the game to be
merit-based and i definitely want people
to win
along the way everybody as much as
possible and i i thank you for saying
that can i know you're on uh yeah can i
just say one last thing of course
today monday today
as we speak
i want people to go to my website
the invisible project
dot io
and click on the discord and you'll get
all the information you need about
the drop
the vlog real quick real quick real
quick i get very worried because people
put up fake urls and things of that
nature i assume on your verified twitter
account the actual right url will be
there correct
yes
good so for everybody if you're curious
if you're like me
and you love that character you're
curious about what they're doing i'm
curious myself
go to go to spike's twitter account i'm
sure the url's there we one i just made
a video i i'm very worried about people
clicking fake urls so let's be uh
careful on that front
legend thank you i will see you plenty
soon and and uh when's your convention
oh v con vcon is may 19 to the 22nd
and where is that
minneapolis minnesota u.s bank stadium
the great spike lee will be there and
prince
we're gonna get something
i would love to we're gonna have prince
prince music has already been locked and
loaded in the stadium that's how much
that means
but we should go by uh
his spot
the studio there's a museum now
oh i don't know i'm not educated on that
part but i would i if i had time i might
the day after v con we'll see how i my
schedule works busy
spike great to see you thank you paisley
park paisley park exactly yeah my man
thank you no thank you we'll talk soon
love you well let's go to the yankee
game together all right
oh you missed
no i grew up yankees i'm raising my kid
mets because of his cousins and the
yankees the yankees won in 94 the
rangers won in 96 and that was a wrap
for me i just need one title it's all
jets knicks now for me but i grew up
exactly the same as you yeah
yankees jets knicks did you did you [ __ ]
with hockey back then or not really
you know i went to ranger game once yeah
cause the god right because the garden
there was a little bit of that yeah yeah
i love you talk soon
you